so the big issues I guess would be the
things that might affect our ability to
survive as a species on the planet that
I think most people religious and
non-religious would agree that that
would be a very bad thing and so the
sort of things that could affect that is
some sort of pandemic overpopulation and
pollution or getting hit by a meteor so
to some extent we need to we may need to
do things like lemonade poverty just so
we have less burden so we can go forward
with our science and engineering enough
so that we can get some of us off the
planet so when the meteor hits we will
still survive so in a way you have to
think in this very interconnected
far-reaching way in order to decide what
the priorities are and at least some of
the priorities must be to get us to a
point where it's not such a luxury to
have science and engineering that's
capable of getting us to another
habitable planet or for that matter
constructing a habitable biosphere
that's non planetary many steps between
there I mean personal genomics and being
able to monitor our environmental
microorganisms and so forth could be a
huge step in towards the reducing
poverty and increasing education so that
then we can do things that involve
physics again
you